Christopher Nolan's "Oppenheimer" throws a
lot at the audience — in a good way.
From the significance of horses to the use
of moody black and white scenes, there's more
to "Oppenheimer" than meets the eye.
At the beginning of the movie, we follow a
young J. Robert Oppenheimer during his studies
in physics across Europe.
While at Cambridge, Oppenheimer is severely
depressed and becomes frustrated with his
highly critical instructor, future Nobel Prize
winner Patrick Blackett.
In an unthinkable fit of anger, he injects
an apple on the professor's desk with deadly
potassium cyanide.
Oppenheimer quickly regrets the decision and
races back to the classroom to dispose of
the apple, only to find his idol, Niels Bohr,
holding it.
Thankfully, the whole affair ends quietly
without anyone taking a bite.
Though dramatized, this bizarre event is based
in real history.
Oppenheimer's poor mental health at Cambridge
is well documented, and according to various
reports he did attempt to poison one of Blackett's
apples.
The severity of the actual encounter is debated,
and it wasn't necessarily anything as dangerous
as cyanide.
The inclusion of Bohr is a fictional addition
from Christopher Nolan, but the kernel of
the story remains true.
Like "Memento," Christopher Nolan's second
film, some scenes in "Oppenheimer" are in
color and others are in black and white.
If you're familiar with his past work, you
might assume that the division is being used
in the same way as the earlier movie — to
differentiate between two different points
in time.
At first, that holds somewhat true, with the
black and white scenes all taking place after
the Manhattan Project.
However, the theory doesn't totally hold up.
Oppenheimer's hearing is shot in color despite
taking place well after World War II.
By the end of the movie, we even get versions
of the same scenes in both color and black
and white.
The real distinction seems to be that the
black and white scenes show things from the
perspective of Lewis Strauss, the primary
villain of the film in its final act.
His congressional hearing and all of his meetings
are shot in black and white, as are his versions
of different encounters with Oppenheimer.
Early in the film, before he's recruited to
lead the Manhattan Project, Oppenheimer's
primary area of study is black holes and neutron
stars.
At the party where he first meets Jean Tatlock,
he's knee-deep in black hole research, clearly
fascinated by the inherent paradoxes of the
field.
When asked, he says that he's studying "how
stars die," adding,
"The bigger the star, the more dramatic its
demise."
This line isn't just science, but a grim bit
of foreshadowing for how Oppenheimer's own
life will end up.
After becoming the most famous scientist in
the world for nightmarish reasons, he tries
to remedy the damage, but fails.
Frustrated by his outspoken opposition to
continued nuclear weapons development, the
U.S. government effectively blacklists him.
The "star" of the country who helped win the
war is ostracized, the gravity of his notoriety
collapsing in on itself.
There's a second sad significance to Oppenheimer's
black hole research, which is that several
of his contemporaries believed he might have
won a Nobel Prize had he continued exploring
that area of quantum physics.
Instead, he largely abandoned the field and
became much better known for the Manhattan
Project.
Though Oppenheimer was nominated for the award
several times in his life, he never won it.
General Leslie Groves is one of the major
players of "Oppenheimer."
He recruits Oppenheimer to helm the Manhattan
Project, and is the driving force in finally
getting him his security clearance.
"This is the most important thing to ever
happen in the history of the world!"
Additionally, he offers genuine advice to
Oppenheimer when the FBI and other intelligence
folks start poking around his life.
Groves also plays a less overt role as a measure
of time in the film.
Over the course of the Manhattan Project,
we see Groves visibly rise through the ranks.
At his first meeting with Oppenheimer, he's
still just a colonel, but he tells the physicist
that he's being promoted to general for his
work on the project.
We then observe Groves as a brigadier general,
and eventually, a major general.
We're not told these things, but the ranks
are shown on his uniform, marking the passage
of time at Los Alamos in a movie that otherwise
does all it can to muddy its chronology.
Groves retired as an honorary lieutenant general
— the rank he held after retirement when
testifying at Oppenheimer's security hearings.
Though he's starred in a ton of major movies
over the years, Cillian Murphy may be best
known today for his leading role of Thomas
Shelby in the British crime drama "Peaky Blinders."
Set in the wake of World War I, the series
follows a Birmingham street gang as it ascends
to international prominence under the leadership
of Murphy's character.
J. Robert Oppenheimer is a very different
character than Tommy Shelby.
However, there is one big similarity between
the two: They both find solace in their relationships
with horses.
In "Peaky Blinders," Tommy is arguably more
comfortable around the animals than he is
around any single human.
He has a deep love and respect for horses
that helps him occasionally escape from his
stressful, criminal life.
In much the same way, Murphy's Oppenheimer
seems happiest when out peacefully in the
New Mexico desert with a horse.
The rest of his life becomes an unceasing
procession of guilt and death after the Manhattan
Project.
When he's out alone with a horse, however,
Oppenheimer seems to find some tranquility.
This almost certainly isn't an intentional
reference, as it merely reflects a true aspect
of Oppenheimer's life.
But given that Tommy Shelby is probably Murphy's
most famous role, the similarity stands out
as a notable little detail.
After his initial relationship with Jean Tatlock
ends, Oppenheimer marries Kitty.
Things go well at first, but life gets tough
after they have their first child, Peter.
Oppenheimer is off organizing the early stages
of the Manhattan Project, and he comes home
one night to find their infant son screaming
and Kitty drunk at the dining room table.
She explains that he's been crying all night.
Distressed and unsure what to do, Oppenheimer
takes his son to the house of Berkeley colleague
and good friend Haakon Chevalier, who watches
over the child for a time.
For the rest of his infancy as depicted in
the film, Peter almost never stops screaming.
He cries when the family moves into Los Alamos,
and he cries at the dinner table.
These details are some of the more fictionalized
parts of "Oppenheimer," but they serve a greater
thematic purpose.
After the Manhattan Project, the physicist
continues to be plagued by screaming, albeit
the imagined kind, as he's haunted by the
horrors of his creation.
His children foreshadow all the death his
inventions ultimately bring.
"I don't know if we can be trusted with such
a weapon."
One small detail at the end of "Oppenheimer"
is that in addition to his affair with Jean
Tatlock, Oppenheimer also slept with close
friend Ruth Tolman during his marriage to
Kitty.
It doesn't affect the story all that much
but is something you might have expected if
you paid attention earlier in the film.
Ruth doesn't get a ton of screen time.
However, she does feature in a few key moments.
In one scene, before Oppenheimer is invited
to join the Manhattan Project, he's in the
room when Ernest Lawrence and Ruth's husband
Richard begin a meeting concerning the operation.
Because he isn't cleared to know about it,
Oppenheimer is asked to leave, and on the
way out he tells Richard to tell Ruth that
he'll be up to visit soon.
At the time, this seems like a harmless comment
to a friend, but it could be read as a hidden
jab.
Tolman gets to be in the room while Oppenheimer
doesn't, and we know from earlier scenes that
he's vindictive.
Later, there's a conversation between Ruth
and Oppenheimer at a party.
While shorter and less suggestive — mirrors
the one he has with Kitty earlier in the movie.
These clues foreshadow their affair, which
is only confirmed at the end.
Some of the small details in "Oppenheimer"
are added for dramatic effect, but a surprising
percentage of them are pulled straight from
the history books.
In addition to the encounter where Oppenheimer
attempts to poison his instructor at Cambridge,
his meeting with Harry S. Truman is pretty
accurate.
According to the Oppenheimer biography "American
Prometheus," Oppenheimer did confess to feeling
like he had blood on his hands to Truman,
and the president did brush him off like he
does in the film.
During the Trinity test, the movie shows Nobel
Prize winner Richard Feynman watching the
explosion without protective glasses, as he
claims that the windshield of his truck will
protect him.
This too is true to life, according to Feynman's
own account in his autobiography.
Additionally, a lot of lines in the movie
were actually spoken by the actual people.
For instance, in his Los Alamos speech, Oppenheimer
did say that he regretted that the bomb couldn't
have been used on the Nazis.
Though it certainly makes some tweaks, "Oppenheimer"
has a lot of great historical details that
really add to the effect.
At the beginning of the film, Oppenheimer
has visions of the subatomic world he's studying.
Niels Bohr speaks about quantum physics like
it's a magical language, asking Oppenheimer,
"Can you hear the music?"
However, these glimpses of a magical world
give way to more nightmarish visions of the
Earth engulfed in flames.
During the Trinity test — the first detonation
of an atomic weapon — the two meld into
one.
It's easy to miss, but as Oppenheimer stares
at the fire from the Trinity explosion, he
sees the glistening particles from his earlier
visions.
The crystallized fragments blur into the flames,
creating a sickening distortion of the thing
that once gave him so much excitement to study
science.
In the wake of Trinity, Oppenheimer never
again sees the beautiful visions from his
youth.
He only sees horrors, fire, and dread.
Throughout "Oppenheimer," there are numerous
references to chain reactions.
Nuclear fission explosions operate off the
basic concept of a chain reaction, and at
one point, the Los Alamos scientists believe
there's a chance that an A-bomb detonation
could start a chain reaction that never stops.
There's a greater-than-zero chance before
the Trinity test that the explosion could
set fire to the entire atmosphere, effectively
destroying the world.
It doesn't, but Oppenheimer believes that
the chain reaction he's started will still
end in Armageddon.
"Now I am become death, the destroyer of worlds."
Going along with this theme, the whole structure
of the movie is like a chain reaction.
We see how certain decisions lead to other
moments all at once.
The beginning, middle, and end of Oppenheimer's
life develop in tandem with each other, giving
the impression of his whole life being a giant
explosion of causality.
Your mileage may vary on where "Oppenheimer"
ranks in the pantheon of Christopher Nolan
movies.
However, one fact is indisputable: The movie
feels like the culmination of many of his
past projects.
The heavy focus on quantum physics can be
tracked back to "Interstellar," which was
praised in its day for being more scientifically
accurate than most sci-fi movies.
The black and white vs. color dynamic and
non-linear narrative echo "Memento," while
the fixation with World War II history evokes
"Dunkirk."
Nolan himself has said that he sees the ending
of "Oppenheimer" as being similar to that
of "Inception," as both leave the audience
with unanswerable questions.
And of course, you could compare the history-altering-weapon
storyline of "Tenet" to the real history of
the Manhattan Project.
Undoubtedly, Nolan still has many movies left
to make.
But the sheer scale of "Oppenheimer" puts
it on the top shelf of his filmography.
Given the wide range of movies the director
has helmed thus far, it should be particularly
interesting to see where he goes from here.